All right. Hello everyone. So it's uh
June 19th, 2026. We're here at the
active inference institute going through
fundamentals of active inference by
Sanjie Namoshi. So today we'll be
covering chapter five, the first half of
chapter 5 on predictive processing. Uh
so this is kind of another aspect of
everything that we've seen so far. Maybe
a different perspective for from which
to view things that maybe we already
know. um in ways that are going to be
fruitful later. Uh now this chapter this
once we get through this chapter this
will mark the end of part one of the
book. So there there are three three
main parts chapters one to five. Um and
the you know the quote foundations
unquote will have been sort of covered
by that point and then the middle part
of the book really is active inference
proper you know where we sort of get
into the method itself. Um, we spent a
long time uh slogging through lots of
detailed background mathematics and
motivation for what we're doing here.
Um, and all of that's extremely
valuable, but I know it has been a bit
of a slog. Um, so next next sort of
session, although we're thinking about
maybe potentially having a review
session for for part one before we get
into um part two. We're not sure about
that. We're going to have to discuss
that. um Andrew and I and and um Daniel.
But nevertheless, chapter 5 is what
we're going to be doing today. I think
really the core of the material for
chapter 5 that we should probably try
and aspire to get through is 5.1 and 5.2
only those two subsections and then the
subsequent subsections are are sort of
yet more elaboration. So before we do
that, I'll just share my screen here and
hopefully everybody will be able to see.
So maybe just the Brave tab
uh window. There we go. Show that. So
hopefully people should be able to see
my screen. Now if we go back to chapter
one, I just want to show uh the
breakdown of the book again.
1.1
maybe it's not there or the
introduction. I think it's actually the
introduction.
Here we go. So
this is uh just a reminder as to the
partition of the book. So we got part
one, part two, part three, chapter five,
predictive coding. This is very much the
capstone of part one on fundamentals and
then we're getting into active inputs
core with part two. So you can see part
five is you know it's a requirement or
strong dependency for a lot of part two.
So it is a valuable perspective to have
when moving on to the you know active
infants proper but it is not the same
thing as active infants and we're going
to see we're going to sort of set up how
it is that it is a different perspective
but that it's not a replacement for
active infants. It really is I like to
think of it as a as just another aspect
for viewing what we've already done with
chapter 4. So maybe just as a as a brief
recap of of chapter 4 I'll come back
over here to the notes. So in chapter
well chapter five
uh what I've done is I've got the we've
got the the outline of the actual sub
subsections um and then I've got the
sort of session objectives the breakdown
into core content and so on and so so
forth like we have before I don't have
the detailed breakdowns of the
subsections just yet. Those are
forthcoming in addition to answers to
questions from chapter 4. I uh I'm a bit
behind there.
But nevertheless, the the general flavor
and overview of chapter 5 is here now.
Um I think I'll go through and clean
things up a little bit.
>> Fraser, sorry to but you're um showing
the wrong screen, I think.
>> Oh dear. Okay. Well, let's fix that. Uh
thank you. Maybe I'll share I'll share
my entire screen and then that fix that.
Okay. Can people see They should be able
to see chapter five now.
Yes.
>> Verbal yes or no? Yep. Cool. Cool. All
right.
>> Okay. So, I was just saying the the
outline for, you know, the outline for
the notes of chapter five, that's in
there. Now, the detailed breakdowns that
I usually do, 5.1, 5.2, and so on,
they're not there. They they'll be
they'll be forthcoming. So, all right.
So, indeed, we're moving from
uh well, I think it'll be be useful
maybe to just kind of meditate upon the
nutshell that I've um identified here.
So, what did we see in chapter one? We
saw that, you know, we're looking at how
we can infer hidden causes from sensory
observations. And indeed, throughout the
entirety of part one of the book, we're
not even concerned with actions at all.
So this this, you know, planning,
action, selection, none of this is what
we're looking at. We're just looking at
perception. So part one is very much
about what does active inference have to
say or what does the constituents of
active inference have to say with
respect to the problem of perception
only. Okay? And then we're going to take
up the problem of action selection
later. So throughout the entirety of of
part one, we're only concerned with
perception and different aspects of the
perception problem in active inference.
So chapter one, we saw how to formalize
the notion of of perception as
[clears throat] inference over latent or
hidden hidden causes given sensory
observations. Uh and we saw the
distinction between the generative model
and the generative process. Okay? And
we've seen that recapitulated across all
of the chapters thus far. uh and then
chapter two that's where we really began
to formalize this mathematically in
terms of hidden state estimation with
bases rule we made simplifying
assumptions about the nature of the
problem we were dealing with so that we
could use bases rule exactly and
precisely okay uh and that was a
concession to you know pedagogical
necessity but we can't actually use
bases rule in the general case for
perception it's just too hard to do the
marginalization to get the model
evidence for for our observations. And
then we saw chapter 3 um we can do this
same process of hidden hidden state
estimation not only for doing perception
of of latent states but learning
parameters in our model. Um, so we're
sort of beginning to see uh the flavor
that's being set up wherein we have this
kind of separation of time scales now
and we have this kind of we're gesturing
toward a hierarchical model where at the
base layer we're doing hidden state
inference and then above that we're
still doing hidden state inference but
we're doing it with respect to model
parameters so that we get the same
structure recapitulated at two levels
and that kind of uh flavor of idea is
going to keep on recurring throughout
the rest of the book and it's going to
show up in predictive coding. in a very
powerful way. Uh this idea of kind of
hierarchical separation of our model. So
that's what we saw in chapter three. And
then chapter four, well towards the end
of chapter 3, we saw a way to you
because that that's that's a problem.
Then if you have this if you're
separating your model into this kind of
hierarchical regime where you've got two
problems that are being solved that are
nevertheless dependent on each other, we
have this issue of kind of well how do
you solve one problem without having
first solved the other and vice versa.
So you know to know to to do inference
on hidden states you have to know the
model parameters and to do model
parameter learning you have to know the
hidden state distribution and then we
saw how to solve that sort of chicken
and egg problem with the expectation
maximization algorithm and that was that
was beautiful that kind of tied together
a lot of loose ends theoretically
speaking um and is is very nice story.
The only problem uh is that we need to
be able to calculate the exact posterior
distribution with expectation
maximization and that is usually
impossible. So that then set up chapter
4 where we said all right we can't
assume any longer that we can calculate
directly the approximate posterior
distribution. So we're going to have to
instead relax our assumptions about what
we can do. And we're going to have to
now move away from exact Beijian
inference to approximate uh Beijian
inference. And that was what chapter 4
was all about. And it motivated the the
introduction of this quantity called
free energy or variational free energy.
Sort of where it comes from and how it's
related to the problem of calculating
the model evidence in our in our um
inference problems. And so we saw that
minimizing variational free energy
allows us to uh approximate uh Beijian
inference to get on our our um
approximate posterior and that it is a
bound on the model evidence. Okay. So
maybe we can't we we don't know the
model evidence uh exactly and it's it's
not possible to calculate exactly but
nevertheless we can bound it with this
other quantity that we can calculate and
by minimization of this other quantity
variational free energy we can
approximate what we would be doing if we
could do inference and that was the
whole story of chapter 4 and it really
culminated in the presentation I don't
know if I'll be able to get it
relatively quickly but it culminated in
the um presentation of different forms
different aspects or facets of you know
how the variational free energy can be
expressed. So we saw okay there's the
there's kind of four canonical forms. We
saw the G form you know and then we saw
the D form and C form and E form. And
these are all different yet equivalent
ways to express the variational free
energy. And they all have their
different and valuable uh
interpretations and are perhaps more
familiar to certain other communities of
people than than than others. Um but
that that was only that was only to
underscore the fact that there is this
quantity that we're trying to
approximate and it can be thought of in
in at least four sort of different ways.
So that was kind of where we left off
with chapter 4. And there was there's a
lot of moving parts that we uh maybe
skipped over or didn't go into enough
detail with respect to. And so I think
for that reason it would be very
valuable to have maybe a recap uh uh
session for like part one maybe with
some emphasis on on chapter 4 and
certainly [clears throat] with respect
to things like
assumptions that are made in inference.
So one of the big assumptions in chapter
4 towards the end we have 4.5 and 4.6
six free form mean field variational
inference that corresponds to a certain
assumption that is made when we do our
variational inference and similarly for
4.6 six fixed form mean variation
operates. We didn't really go over that
in a lot of detail and uh we don't need
to but it is it is an important uh thing
to uh to go over because these things
show up in in chapter five now on
predictive coding. So that's where we
left off from and that's what we're
that's the perspective from which we're
now going into predictive coding which
is so this is chapter five.
This is now in some sense not a
presentation of new material but as I
say a different way of thinking about
the variational inference problem that
we've um we've set up now from from
chapters one to uh to four. So I want to
get the let's get the actual
uh chapter breakdown
which is
where is it here.
>> Sure.
Yeah.
>> So yeah, as I say for variation free
energy, we're going to start out in 5.1
with this idea of prediction errors and
precision weighted prediction errors and
we're going to see how they related to
the quantity of variational free energy.
That's kind of the big takeaway of of
this entire chapter is that we can kind
of reformulate what we've been talking
about with variational free energy in
terms of this other mathematical
construct called prediction errors.
Precision weighted prediction errors,
square prediction errors. uh there's a
couple of different ways to to talk
about them. The other parts of the
chapter really in some sense boil down
to various assumptions that are useful
to make when we're doing when we're
instantiating the process of prediction
error minimization computationally. So
we're going to see that maybe in some
instances it's better to simply assume
that we're only concerned with the mean
of our variational density and we don't
care about the the uh the variance at
all. that then leads into you know a
simple notion of predictive coding and
there's some algorithms around that and
then from there we can build out into
hierarchical predictive coding um and
then multivariate predictive coding. So
there's lots of places we can go after
that but the central idea is that there
is a way to recast what we've been doing
in terms of um this this precision
weight prediction error perspective.
Okay. And the idea is that we're going
to see there's kind of two canonical
kinds of prediction error. there's this
state prediction error. So errors about
with respect to my belief about the
hidden states and then also sensory
prediction errors. They're the kind of
two canonical ones we're we're going to
butt up against. So that's where we're
going. You know, we start the chapter
with the E form. Let's come back here.
So that's uh equation 5.1.
So this is this is from section 5.1. we
we're going to start kind of massaging
around um what we've seen before
specifically the E form into these
prediction errors. Basically in
principle you can start with any of the
four canonical de decompositions of the
free energy but um it is useful to start
from the the E form in this particular
case. Um the sort of the move that is is
going to be made is that we're going to
relax uh we're going to we're going to
add assumptions to what we're going to
be modeling um or rather the nature of
the variational posterior and then from
that we're going to be able to make the
the process of computing variational
free energy easier because of the
assumptions that we had in. So we're
going to look at those assumptions. Now,
there's a lot of, you know, motivation
and hand waving on my behalf. Is there
any questions at this point about the
trajectory that we've been on and maybe
where we're going to? I just like to
maybe stop for that if if possible.
>> Uh, just a quick point. Uh Frasier, I
noticed in the summary the E forms signs
are flipped from what we see here and I
saw it presented in the same form as we
see here, but somehow the summary have
the the two signs flipped. Did you
notice that?
>> Yeah. So, well, hang on. In the uh are
you referring to are you referring to
this here or the representation on page
103?
>> Yeah. Well, um in the in the um index or
uh in the uh appendix plus in the
summary at the end of chapter 4.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> In that summary, uh those signs are uh
flipped from what we see currently see
here.
>> And you're right. All I can think of is
it's an IDA in the um summary unless I'm
missing something fundamentally about
how energy or entropy is um is defined
but uh that's just an observation. We
don't have to dwell on it now.
>> No, for sure. I I I did notice that. I
think the reason is because um
a lot of the time or some of the time
you want to talk about negative
variational free energy. So I'm just
trying to find the figure. I don't think
I'll be able to do it in time where he
has that summary. Um the the more
canonical way to represent if I go back
to uh the actual equation
I would say that the more canonical way
that uh so that we would represent this
this quantity here is the negative of
what you're looking at here. So what we
saw before okay where you have you know
a positive energy minus an entropy.
Okay. So this this here would be the
negative variational free energy in that
interpretation. So I'm not quite sure
why that perspective has flipped. I
think it needs to be noted that it has
been flipped otherwise it's nata. So
yeah that's um an important observation
but again we don't have to be too hung
up on that because it doesn't matter if
we're flipping our perspective about
sort of minimizing
um you know negative variational free
energy or maximizing elbow. Those are
two complimentary perspectives. So
>> is it okay if I chime in real quick? So
uh sorry the um I I noticed as well if
we look at equation I think it's 4.29A
uh in chapter 4. So that's that's not
the end of chapter 4 where we get like
the re-representations of all the
different forms using varth theta
instead of x. This is the earlier the
first time the e form is introduced. And
yes, it is the case that the initial uh
term is is like a um a negative uh he
uses a a negative in uh negative energy.
And then here uh in chapter 5
the
yeah the the terms are a little bit
different. I think they're flipped
around a little bit. So, we have, excuse
me, we have negative entropy in the
4.29.
Um, so that kind of explains, well, no,
that doesn't quite explain whenever I'm
flipping back and forth how it's
represented. We Sorry, I I thought I had
something much more focused to say, but
now that I'm looking back and forth
while I'm speaking there, there's
something not quite right about those. I
realize that the now the energy term is
on the left and the entropy is on the
right whereas whenever we're first
introduced to it we have uh negative
entropy on the left and average energy
on the right and we're actually
subtracting the the energy. So no that
that's correct. The
>> yes I guess the difference
>> entropy is still a problem. Yeah you
know
>> this the difference between this and um
5.1. So you know entropy is obviously is
defined as the negative integral of you
know q of x log q of x. So taking the
negative of that would just destroy the
negative and you would just have this
integral. So and that would then make
the the average energy positive. you
know, if I took the negative this whole
thing. But yeah, I I don't like that
that move has been made without having
been said that it's been made. Um, yeah,
for sure. So, I think uh I think what
we'll do is we'll we'll have to report
that as as a potential era to come back
upon and because it would you you want
to have the forms it would be nice to
have the forms of the the free energy,
you know, consistent throughout um
throughout the chapters, not really
within a chapter.
Yeah. Okay. Well, let us just take the E
form as it is given here because it
doesn't matter too much whether we're
talking about negative expected free
energy or or elbow sort of positive
expected free energy. What we do is we
we sort of take a move where we want to
interpret this in a slightly different
way. So that's sort of 5.2 here. I'll
get to some um uh some figures. I know
that waiting through maths is never too
too handy, but 5.2 too.
The idea is that um we're going to sort
of reinterpret what we've seen by merely
merely concerning ourselves with the
mean of the approximate uh posterior
distribution. Okay, so we're going to we
know that our approximate posterior
distribution or at least we assume that
our approximate posterior distribution
is going to be a Gaussian distribution.
Okay, so there's a mean and a variance
that characterizes that. And we're just
going to assume that we can adequately
characterize the approximate posterior
by means of its mean only. Okay, so
that's this mux here. So again, x is our
hidden state. Y is our observation. Uh
and so what we do is we say let's just
throw away all the information about the
variance. We we're only concerned with
the mean. That's what this expression
here corresponds to. Uh, and this is
very nice because what this allows us to
do is completely eliminate the entropy
term. So if I go back here to um 5.1,
we no longer have to care about this
entropy over here. I don't want to go
through the mathematical reasons why
precisely other than to say that entropy
is in some sense a measure of the spread
of a distribution. And if there is if we
assume that there is no spread then
there's no entropy and we can only
concern ourselves with the energy term
which is quite nice. That's a
simplifying assumption.
Obviously that assumption is going to
work in some cases and it's not going to
work in others. So it's definitely not a
panacea and that's what we're that's
what we're left with here. We're just
left with the energy term which you can
express in in one of two different ways.
He does he does say in the text that
we're going to make use of the direct
delta distribution. That's what this um
Greek letter delta blah blah blah is.
Okay, so this sort of comes from
physics. Um it's merely a way to pretend
that we have a distribution
quote unquote at a single value. Okay,
so whatever this delta thing is, uh it's
zero everywhere except for x - mu and
the area under the curve even though
there is no curve is one. Okay, so it's
a very very weird distribution. It
exists essentially for bookkeeping
purposes to reflect the assumptions that
we've made. I don't want to get into
those details because they're not too
relevant. But the all all that is to say
is that if we throw away information
about the variance, we're left only with
the mean and then we only have to care
about the energy term, the the
variational free energy,
>> which is
>> in a in a sense. It it makes intuitive
sense because the delta's height is
infinite.
So the one could imagine that the area
under the curve is still one.
>> Yeah, exactly. So this is in some sense
what the delta distribution looks like.
It's very very weird. It's zero
everywhere and then it's infinite
infinitely high at zero. Uh and so what
you can do the key property
the key property of the delta
distribution is you can do this thing
called sifting
where if you've got some function f of f
of t uh and then you multiply it with
the direct delta at t minus c that will
actually once you integrate over the
domain that will give you the value of
your function at c. So all that is to
say is that it's a way of you've got
some function. It's a way of picking out
what that function's value is at a
certain point. Okay, at one point that's
kind of the crucial uh you know thing
that it's used to do. So where does this
leave us? Where does that give us? That
gives us 5.3 now where and again this
this sort of comes from the latter part
of of chapter 4 where we can now say
we've got our energy term.
We can express it as the negative log
probability of our generative model P of
X and Y. We know what X is. It's modeled
only by the mean. And then by the rules
of probability, we can we can factoriize
this up into a a likelihood, an
observation likelihood minus our prior
on on X. Uh and this this is uh now our
approximate form for the variational
free energy. Technically it's the
maximum aposteriori estimate for the
variational free energy. We have we have
technically covered maximum apostoi
estimates uh in chapter 4 but as I say
that's one of the things that we didn't
spend as much time on as perhaps we need
to. So we we'll probably have to go back
and and review some of that material.
What does this leave us with? Well, I'm
glad you asked. Let's go to 5.4 now. Uh
5.4a. There we go.
So he says this is on page 104 now. Um
so we used uh we use this quantity to
determine the maximum aosto estimate for
x the hidden state now evaluated at mux
only the mean of the approximate
posterior only. U so this defines the
mean of the log likelihood to be
generated using some arbitrary
generating function gm mux. So this is
the as we've seen before this is the
function that's going to give us our
observation mapping. Okay, we saw that
from chapter 2 and such like but we're
only evaluating it with respect to the
mean now which simplifies things. Uh now
we notate this likelihood so the
observation likelihood and the prior
with the following two Gaussian
distributions. So [clears throat]
5.4 for a well technically
this whole thing should be we're going
to assume that the probability of
observations given our hidden state is
equal to a Gaussian distribution. All
right and one given by this form here
and then we're also going to assume that
our prior over hidden states so the
probability that the hidden state is
equal to the mean is some other Gaussian
distribution. All right. [clears throat]
So the the the the hidden state prior
distribution is going to have parameters
mx and sx squared. Uh and then the
observation likelihood parameters are
going to be the generative model and
sigma y^ 2. I it's not too important to
to worry about that bookkeeping but it
is useful when we come to the actual
what's coming next 5.5
the expression of these prediction
errors and sort of where they come from.
So following the same procedure
explained in chapter 2.5.1
subsection, we can plug the formula for
these Gaussian probability
distributions. This one here for our
observation likelihood. And by the way,
this this expression is incomplete.
We'll we'll complete it. And this other
Gaussian distribution for our prior
overhead states, we can plug those into
the formula for Gaussian probability
probability distributions.
Uh, we can plug this into equation 5.3,
which is what? It's our expression for
the variational free energy. I want to
go back up and show you.
In order to get the expression for the
VF in terms of things that are quite
easy to calculate,
uh, I'm not finding it. I'm not finding
it. Here we go. So, this is our this is
our approximate
version of the the the VF in terms of
things that are relatively easy to
calculate. Let's take those two
distributions, our likelihood and our
prior, plug them in. What do we get? We
get equation 5.5.
This one here.
Aha. Now, this is excellent. So this is
the the resulting equation for the
variational free energy that we get if
we have made the assumptions that we
have made which is that we can assume
the the variational posterior is well
approximated by its mean only um and
that the likelihood of observations and
the prior belief by hidden states are
both Gaussian distributions. If you plug
those Gaussian distributions into the
form of the variational free energy that
we got, you get this here which is
crucially something. So there's this
there these two terms are going to be
the crucial terms here. What are they?
They're in some sense you can see
there's the difference of things here.
So if we just if we just read this top
one this whole thing is a squared value
of what your observation minus so by the
way y is the actual observation you're
getting in that minus your predicted
observation okay so g of mu of x this is
our model for what we think observations
are going to be given uh given our
belief about hidden states that whole
thing is what's known as a prediction
error
uh because it is literally the
difference between our actually observed
value and our predicted value. We square
that whole thing and we divide it by the
variance of the uh likelihood
model. So we have this prediction error.
This this can typically be notated by
and you'll see this again and again if
you read papers in sort of predictive
processing it's very common to represent
prediction errors by this Greek letter
epsilon, right? So E of Y. So in some in
some sense this is our a measure of the
error that we have in our predictions
with respect to observations and we have
exactly the same expression for the
error with respect to our belief about
hidden states.
So we assume well we we we assume that
the hidden state is mu of x. Uh but then
we can subtract the predicted value of
the mean from our prior and we can get
our prediction error over uh the the the
hidden state as well. These two
quantities are the central quantities.
These are what's known as the prediction
errors. Okay. And there's other things
going on that I don't want to talk about
that are not very relevant. And so that
that culminates then Oh, do we have a
comment? Sorry, just a quick question.
Uh, I noticed you call the MX the
predicted value. Uh, why why do you say
that?
>> Well, predicted in the sense that it is
our prior estimate for the if I go back
to um what is it here? 5.4b.
So, it's predicted in the sense that
it's what we expect the mean to be
before we've made an observation. That's
the only sense in which I meant
predicted. Um I want four 4.5
5.4 rather. Sorry that's all I meant by
that. Maybe that was confusing um or or
sloppy. Uh
>> yeah, a nice way to think about those
two terms are also that um mx is the
belief and then uh before before the
data and mux is after the data. So it's
the new value of the mean of the
posterior after the data.
>> Yeah, that's that is a that's a
wonderful interpretation um and a better
way to say it I think than what I did
say. So absolutely. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So the so the m of x is the prior
state estimate uh state it's the state
prior that the model holds. Um I think
we all understand that much. So it is
fair to say it's predicted in the sense
that everything related to X in the
model is being predicted right because
it doesn't know the true state of the
world. So just like from a theoretical
aspect it's fair to call it predicted
but then that said it's the mu of X that
is getting updated right that's what's
that's what's getting computed after the
data is received whereas the M of X
would be prior to the data being
received. And so whenever we're doing
state prediction error in that var
epsilon of x, we're taking our update
and then subtracting out the prior from
what we thought it was before. So it's
as if we're saying, well, if we had
relied upon the prior, mu of x would
have been this, right? So if that
difference is very very small, it close
to virtually zero, that would be saying
our mu of x is virtually the same as m
of x. we have zero prediction error and
it's saying we hardly had to update
anything at all uh in order to to come
up with this new mu of x estimate. Um
and we get that same kind of logic here
with the var epsilon of y for the
observation prediction error. Um it
would be the same sort of thing. the
model updates its uh its parameters etc
in order to improve its generating
function that g of um the the gm of of
uh m of x I think uh in order to compute
what it thinks y would be. So similarly
if we can get that observation
prediction error virtually to zero that
means we hardly had to update our model
in order to achieve a good estimate. So
the whole thing with prediction error is
that it allows us to see how well our
model is doing two things. How well it's
predicting observations and how well
it's predicting um hidden states. And
then we see in the chapter elsewhere
that these two things tend to both get
updated whenever we change our mu of x
whenever we update that because they
both rely upon the mu of x in their
respective equations. So they're they're
very um Sanjief says they're coupled uh
which is an important thing to to know
about them. So any anyway just wanting
to add to all of that.
>> Yeah. It's consistent in both cases.
It's after minus before.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Because otherwise
>> well said the whole the whole motivation
is you know we have our prediction error
with sensory observations and obviously
hidden states. you can't have an error
with respect to things that you predict
if you don't get in something after
you've made your prediction. So it is
there's always this temporal aspect uh
with prediction errors. That's a very
important um point to to to highlight.
Uh you're exactly right with respect to
that kvis. So these are our two
prediction errors that we're going to
care about. Sensory prediction error and
hidden state prediction error. Now he
goes through with you know 5.7 A and B
uh and says look you can you can express
your prediction errors uh with you know
by means of the either the variance of a
Gaussian distribution or the precision
of a Gaussian distribution. I don't want
to get too tied up on that other than to
say that variant what precision is the
inverse of the variance. Um so what the
crucial thing though in either case is
to note if we look at our actual
expression for the maximum asteriori
estimate for the variational free energy
in terms of prediction errors you'll see
that we have our prediction errors but
they're also they're weighted by this
term or these two terms here. So in this
case they're weighted by the variance of
so the sensory prediction is weighted by
the variance of the uh observation
likelihood and the state prediction is
weighted by the variance of the prior
over states. You can just say look I
don't care about variances I care about
inverse variances and weight them with
this lambda y. So this is exactly the
same. This is literally just one over
the variance of y and one over the
variance of x. So you'll a lot of times
we want to talk about precision weighted
prediction error and that's what this is
here. So these things are precisions.
They're inverse variances and they
weight the prediction errors. So this is
usually the setup that you'll see with
when we're talking about prediction
errors. We're usually talking about
precision weighted prediction errors.
Okay. So
>> in um in 5.7b
that minus should probably be a plus.
Would you agree?
uh for the inverse precision. So this
one here.
>> Yeah, that that central term. Shouldn't
that be a plus? Pl plus you know.
>> Yes.
Yes, it should. It should be. So that's
I I'll note that here is an erata. I
believe it should.
So we want plus
log in
not lights. Yeah, I think I think you're
right about that. I'll I'll go back and
uh and see.
All right. Okay. So, we we're now
actually going to contextualize things
and not just kind of throw away throw
around mathematical relationships. So,
there are there are a lot of examples in
this section. I don't know if we'll be
able to get through all of them, but
example 5.1 is kind of the central one
and the one that's hopefully most um
illuminating with respect to what so
it's explicit that you know what is the
relationship between the VF and
prediction errors. Okay. Um maybe the
last thing I'll say so we we have this
expression for the VF in terms of
prediction errors. Okay, just one thing
about prediction errors. Obviously you
would like to
uh so the idea is that if you have if
you have very small prediction errors
then that is in some sense um that
corresponds to having minimum VF and we
want to minimize our VF to have a better
approximate posterior. So that's good.
It's not necessarily the case that
prediction error is just a bad thing.
It's what it is is a signal that your
model is uh not quite adequate. So it's
not usually the case that you want to
completely eradicate all prediction
error. Um because you'll see that really
the thing that we care about is
precision weighted prediction error. But
if you have a very very small or very
big prediction error, but it's quite
imprecise,
that that doesn't really tell you a lot.
So imagine this, this is a this is an
example that's used a lot. Imagine
you're sort of driving late at night.
You're in a car and it's very foggy out.
You've got your your headlights, right?
So what you want to do is you want to
and you you can't see very far ahead of
you because of the fog. You typically
don't want to just kind of look
anywhere. You want to look in clearings
in the fog because they give you very
precise information about how wrong your
model of the world is. So maybe there's
a deer there, maybe it's a person, I
don't know, but you would like to attend
to, you know, things that are g giving
you precise information as opposed to
just any feedback at all. Um, so that's
a subtle point and we're going to come
back to it many times, but it's the
crucial thing is this precision weighted
prediction error, not just the
prediction error itself. So I did uh
want to mention that.
Okay, so
let's actually look at some some things
now, not just equations. That's chapter
four.
Chapter five. Very nice. So the the the
the example that I think is the most
important example is I say 5.1 that's in
figure 5.5
5.3 sorry this one here.
So the whole point about this example is
you know we're meant to be getting some
intuition about the relationship between
VF and prediction error. Um what he
assumes is that we can just get rid of
the variances and precisions. We can
assume that they're one. So we end up
with just you know the the map estimate
is 1/2 of state prediction error plus
observation prediction error. Okay. Um
that's all very nice. So the the so the
caption reads look the the intuition for
understanding VF and prediction error.
So on the left hand side we have VF as a
function of different values of mu of X.
So these are our our means right and
then we're just plotting the VF uh with
respect to that that particular value of
of the mean.
So the blue dot denotes the true hidden
state XAR that's the the actual hidden
state in the general process. The red
dot denotes the minimum of VF. Okay. So
the the minimum of the VF is around
about here. There's the value of the
hidden state that you would get at the
minimum of the VF.
Uh and the green dot is there a green
dot? Yeah, there's one here. Uh that
indicates the prior mean. Okay. Uh for
for our prior belief about the hidden
state. So the dotted this is the
important point. The dotted lines
represent the surprisal limit. Okay. So
obviously the thing that we care most
about is surprisal. Um so that you know
the blue arrow this shows the distance
from the minimum of VF to the true
hidden state. So you can see this value
of the the hidden state that we get if
we just minimize the VF is not exactly
equal to the real hidden state. There's
some error there. Okay, that's what this
blue arrow is meant to be representing.
Um
now the green arrow shows the distance
from the minimum of the VF to the prior
mean. Okay, so this is obviously a
bigger our our prior belief about the
hidden state is is is well the error in
that is bigger than the uh the resulting
belief that we would get if we just
minimize vf.
Uh now on the right we see the squared
weighted prediction errors as a function
of x. So we see this the the orange line
says the squared weighted prediction
error over states and the blue line is
the squared weighted prediction error
over observations.
[clears throat]
>> Just question the the green mux is that
the prior mean or the posterior mean?
>> That's the that's the pri the prior I
understood that to be the prior mean of
the um the hidden state distribution.
[clears throat] Yeah. What did you say
here? The green dot indicates the prior
mean. Yeah. Well, yeah.
Uh potentially a little bit confusing
because really the prior mean is MX.
Uh and mux is our our approximate
uh posterior mean. So this really should
be MX I think. Um yeah. So maybe that's
another point of of
>> Yeah.
little odd these uh samuradas thrown
about, but it is uh I think it still
gets the point across, right? that um as
we move
um you know as we kind of see where the
red dot is and how this update happens
um like two things that go together that
we're seeing are f being minimized as
well as uh a change in the prediction
errors. And then another thing that I
just wanted to add is that as far as the
prediction errors go and this whole
aspect of of not just um having
prediction errors but having squared
precision weighted prediction errors is
that the the precision weighted. Now
recall that precision is the inverse
variance. So that variance term is our
model's ability to sort of say like what
is how spread out is this distribution
that we're using this normal
distribution that we're using to try and
predict a state estimate. And so what's
happening is that if the variance on
that is very very high it's a very
imprecise sort of distribution. It's
saying like well x could be 0.5 but it
could also be 7 it could also be 02 and
it could als it could be a variety of
things and it's there's a lot of kind of
probability density spread out amongst
them. Um it's kind of like saying well I
have a best guess which is the mean but
I don't feel very confident in it. It's
very uh imprecise. And so if we have a
very low precision and we multiply that
by the prediction error, we're saying,
well, we could have a very high
prediction error, but I'm not very
confident or I have very low precision
in my model in the first place, which
would then weight the prediction error
and bring it much further down. So if
prediction error gets brought down due
to low precision that means we might
make hardly any update or view this as a
particularly heavy problem. It's kind of
saying, "Oh, I uh I don't have a lot of
trust in my sensor that I use to read
the data." And so even though it's
generating prediction errors because I
also don't trust it very much, I'm going
to kind of ignore some of those
prediction errors. Like I don't know how
well I could those prediction errors
would arise from a trustworthy signal.
Right? So I I hope that that maybe
expands the intuition a little bit more.
And the primary thing is just seeing how
f and prediction error are related
because the prediction error remains
something that you know we of course see
in active inference. We see it in other
fields more generally and a lot of other
kinds of computations and it's such a
ubiquitous sort of thing in uh machine
learning and deep learning and and all
of these other kind of predicted
predictive um fields where we're looking
at what was the actual thing that
happened and what did you predicted?
What was the difference? because we know
that in some way we might need to
correct our model for dealing with that
difference. And so in active inference
here we're we're looking at using um
prediction error done in this way where
not only do we have prediction error but
we can actually down or upscale it based
on how much we trust or rather how
precise our uh our our distributions
we're using are. Um so it's kind of like
a parameter on the prediction error. How
much can we trust these prediction error
signals?
>> Yeah, that uh that brings us to I don't
want to there's a lot of meditation that
can be had upon uh so figure 5.4
uh like a nan thing.
>> Fraser may I ask a question please?
>> Yes please please.
>> Yeah yeah yeah I have a question um a
little bit philosophical for the for the
moment. Okay. Um my question is this.
Can you give me provide some insight
about what you just said about
prediction um errors with regards to
mimetic uh compressibility?
So in other words, you you're talking I
think I'm hearing that when you're
talking about you don't have a lot of
trust, you have to ignore the prediction
error. Are you talking about a
circumstance where you you you know the
whatever this this information
processing thing is is working on that
you have to decide on compressing
information for the time being because
there's not a lot of trust in the
information that's coming in. So you
choose uh um you compress the
information momentarily until you have
more information more uh trustworthy
information. Am I am I understanding
this connection or not?
>> Yeah. So um
the thing the if I hear you correctly I
mean the um the point that I think
you're stressing is that there are some
predictions because here's the problem.
What should I predict?
>> Yeah. You know, so there's all kinds of
predictions I could make, but only some
of them are relevant for the ongoing,
you know, autopoetic maintenance of
agency and such like and the claim that
is being made with with the predictive
processing sort of framework is that you
should probably pay attention to those
errors that are very that give you very
precise information about the uh the the
process at issue. So precisely because
there's so many things that you you
could pay attention to. Um, is that kind
of what you were getting at with uh like
why why is it that the the precision is
relevant to prediction error? Is that
was was that kind of your question?
>> Um, well, I'm just I I just want to kind
of think about, you know, when you're
talking about
circumstances under which there is very
low trust in the information that you
have in front of you. So, you don't have
a you you don't have a lot of trust.
What do you do? Do you ignore the
prediction error? What you know? And I'm
trying to figure out where in the math
>> one looks for this and and maybe I'm not
asking the question at the right moment
um in terms of you know all of the
different mathematical modeling that
goes into um what we're doing. But I I
am curious because
it has big implications for a lot of the
work that I do where
>> right
>> you know um agents are exposed to
certain uh information. What do you
trust? What don't you trust? And and so
so I'm not I'm not thinking in terms of
having lots of different types of
information coming in. the agent already
has focused on the fact that it has to
get through the fog and avoid hitting a
deer.
>> Right? So, so what I'm trying to to
connect is to the math. Like I don't
want the math to just be symbols. I want
to be able to see something in the math
so I can remember it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Respect to how much
time we have left. Um can I'll just take
a quick crack at that. Uh so so it's a
great question and it it it it I very
much agree it comes up in real world
circumstances. So um if we imagine sort
of an agent who's um you know imagine a
place it could be with the fog or it
could be they're they're kind of in the
dark or a place that's very uh not well
lit. And so there's this kind of high
variance on on um the the predictions
that they're able to make like the
distribution that they're using to make
those kinds of predictions. And so in
this case, the agent, you know, if you
imagine a real person who like kind of
vaguely hallucinates something like,
"Oh, I thought I saw a person. I'm in
I'm in the woods in the dark and I
thought I saw like something move, but
I'm not really sure. It's it's dark.
There's a lot of wind." Right? So, it's
a very uh um uh imprecise sort of
distribution that they're able to use to
make these kinds of predictions. Um that
is the very high variance. So again that
that sigma um_y
squared is going to be very high. Uh in
that case the agent will have prediction
errors. Oh I didn't think I would see a
person but now I think I have. However
it's very dark so maybe I'm wrong.
Right? And so that'll downscale that
prediction error uh such that the update
that gets made might not advance to
saying oh that was definitely a person.
Right? It's like I thought I might have
seen a person but it's very dark so I'm
not going to assume that was necessarily
a person even though in daytime I think
if I saw that exact thing it probably
would be a person right so it's kind of
like you have a different variance based
on um current circumstances and then
importantly based upon what we've
learned so far only up to chapter 5 so
that we can stay kind of coherent with
what we've learned so far because there
will be much more in the coming chapters
that I think will address this kind of
question even further and supply even
more methods for dealing with it. But
what we've learned so far is one uh we
can learn the variance itself like we
can do a kind of uh estimation or
parameter learning or otherwise that
allows us to change that variance. It's
the kind of thing what that would allow
an agent to say oh I predict that it's
nighttime and it's dark therefore I
should update my variance to say it
should be higher. I might not see what I
think I see in the dark versus in the
daytime. Right? So you can actually
learn the variance which also inversely
means you learn the precision which then
means you learn how much you should pred
trust or not trust your prediction
errors contextually and that's the
important part that's what allows for
further adaptation because what we've
seen so far is that uh Sanjieve at
various points makes major
simplifications on certain parts of a
model just so that he can demonstrate
the other parts that are currently uh in
question like right here uh like the
examples we were looking at, he actually
fixes precision. We're not updating it
at all. Uh he says we're actually gonna
we're going to fix the variance at one
and then because precision is the
inverse of that, we're also fixing
precision at one, right? So it's not
changing at all. So that would also mean
if that agent had very high variance,
they're stuck with that forever. They're
kind of stuck in the dark forever
without being able to to change that uh
or or or increase their precision. So
it's all to say that uh hypothetically
almost any part of any of these models
can be parameterized and be updated
themselves. The variance and precision
can be updated. The hidden state mean
and and likelihood just as we've already
seen in chapter 3 can already be
updated. Uh any of these things can be
adaptively updated. And then finally,
what kind of links all of that in active
inference is that we get to use free
energy as sort of this sort of unifying
way of updating literally anything uh at
any time uh by finding kind of the the
the part the partial derivative the the
free energy as a functional uh with
respect to the thing that we're trying
to update. We just look at everything
else in order to update the one thing in
question that we want to update. So we
do that for the precision and that will
allow an adaptive way of learning when
to trust and not trust your your sensory
signals and your prediction errors. I
hope that was useful. We I promise we
will see much more on that and maybe
slightly more concrete applications as
we get deeper into the book and get more
expressly into what makes active
inference active inference because
chapter 5 is still predictive coding and
it it's it's kind of in ways gets
subsumed into active inference but it's
also as we saw kind of coming out of its
own tradition. It's kind of a
transformation of the Ral Ballard
formulation in some ways too. So, we're
not fully in the realm of active
inference, even though we've definitely
been uh it's been on the table the whole
time. Yeah,
>> that was super helpful. Thank you so
much.
>> You're welcome.
>> I just like I'd like to go to to Gian
Quo, but I'll just note that next time
so next time, next session, we'll be
going over 5.3 and so on. There's a very
nice example where he gives this
motivation of an agent looking for food.
Um, and this shows up in in uh figure 5
something, I think. But that is very
much a practical example. We're going to
see okay where do the prediction errors
and where do the positions come in for
this very practical example I've been
speaking very abstractly for for the
first part and I know I have been um and
I know that's not too helpful but so we
will see that next time I promise. So
Jen Cuomo uh a question from you.
>> Yes. uh it just specifically about this
isn't if I so I isn't the entropy in the
E form the term that carries uh the
variability and therefore the confidence
in the agent's
uh you know ability to to to to to
uh to estimate the posterior so I mean
in a way we we killed off you made him
certain by putting by putting a direct
distribution you kind of made it
deterministic so you don't have he is
not uncertain about what he's doing now
I mean if I I somewhere I was reading
about people discussing in in in an AI
context the use of active inference
where they said that this term here is
actually really important in a future
where you could imagine a model
answering your questions but being
indogenously able to tell you this is
the answer I'm giving you but I'm not
really certain so don't really take my
word for [clears throat] it I have to do
more search no
>> and
>> y
>> am I am I on the wrong right path here
in a way we kind of
>> we kind of killed off this ability to to
to to self uh uh of self-doubt by
killing off the entropy and we leaving
the energy am I is is it kind of correct
>> yeah well we we made very strong
assumption about the nature of the
approximate posterior belief about the
hidden state that it is not really a
distribution and that's
>> kind of wrong for most most cases. Um
we'll see that this is actually so it is
definitely a very strong assumption. it
makes the mathematics a lot easier to do
uh and for for practical purposes it can
be very powerful but yeah we we are
paying a significant theoretical price
here with respect to our ability to uh
account for uh you know the variability
of our belief. So that is something that
is that's a trade-off and it's a
trade-off that we have to know when is
valuable to make and when it's not
valuable to make. So towards the end of
the chapter he'll talk about that
trade-off but you are absolutely correct
in the sense that we are making a
trade-off here. Um, and we need to be
explicit about that. We can't just
pretend that this is always a wise
decision or always something that we we
can or should do. Um, later in the book,
we'll also see what's known as the Llass
approximation, which is a very similar
kind of approximation. Um, but yeah, no,
you're totally right. Totally right
about that. So, I tell you what, guys,
I'm going to stop the recording here,
but I'll still be uh available to take
some questions after the recording. Next
time I think we'll So what did we leave
off? We left off at kind of halfway
between well really I would say figure
sorry example 5.1
um 5.2 then we talk about sort of
prediction errors when we have kind of
non-unit variances and we look at the
relationship between it's still abstract
we're looking at the relationship
between the the prediction errors with
respect to different settings of the
variances or precisions.
uh and then we actually go to an example
in 5.2. I think we'll start with the
example in 5.2 and that will then bring
us to the other concrete example which
is the very concrete one in 5.3. We have
an actual agent that's moving around
looking for food um and and everything
sort of contextualized in a very nice
way. Hopefully that will then make
things a bit more concrete. So
>> all right, I'll end the session. Thank
you very much for people online. Oh,
Andrew, one last word.
>> Yeah, I'm sorry. I uh just for the sake
of recording it rather than not u I I do
want to point out and and we won't have
time to go into it right now but uh just
on that yeah that last question with
respect to the entropy term yeah it is
it is very tricky because as you all
said the the entropy term does sort of
disappear whenever we do this kind of
clamping right because whenever we clamp
we are removing any kind of uncertainty
over the agents like state estimation
it's just kind of reducing everything
down to a single point the probability
of that being exactly that point is a is
sort of a one and so the entropy goes
away. Um yes it makes things much easier
but then as Frasier said there are major
implications to that because we're no
longer able to use kind of the
uncertainty around state estimation when
we're uh computing f. Um and meanwhile
the flip side of that that I wasn't
mentioned was um there's this reference
to the maximum entropy principle which
is quite interesting because it would
say that whenever you whenever you get
started say you sort of deploy an agent
in an environment where it fully knows
nothing it's received no observations
about that environment before it would
actually say that you want your prior to
have very very high entropy which is the
absolute difference. you want that
entropy to be there uh that term to be
there and you want it to be very high.
Um it it it it turns out that if you
follow through this and this is from um
um Dr. Jane uh James who uh wrote this
in 1957 in the realm of like information
theory. The idea is that if you start
with a very high entropy prior which
would be very [clears throat] uncertain.
It kind of looks like a uniform
distribution. and it's like well the
hidden state could be two, it could be
five, it could be a million uh all with
equivalent probability. Then in that
case, you're kind of on a good footing
to be able to take in an observation and
start to figure out the direction you
need to go for forming your your your
hidden state um estimate. If you start
off with a highly precise one, however,
where where there's very low entropy,
that means your model is already biased
towards at least one or some subset of
particular values. That means if you
receive an observation that that
thoroughly conflicts with that, you're
going to have a lot more updating to do
to get back into the right direction. So
you actually typically would want to
start with very uniform prior or very
highly entropic prior so that you have
an equal chance for any uh anywhere you
need to go whatever direction you need
to go based upon the actual observations
you start getting. Um so that that that
was a lot to say but but you get some
references to it in the chapter. There's
further reading and and James's um yeah
principle of maximum entropy. And then
as far as current research and active
inference, I'd also recommend looking at
the maximum caliber principle which is
sort of the same thing um but but it's
but it's um but it's moving towards
paths. So entire looking at sort of the
entropy of an entire trajectory estimate
not just a singular um not just for a
hidden state but a hidden state sort of
over time. Um so that's an innote for
anyone who's interested in that or kind
of looking to get more out of this
chapter. Um but yeah, thanks Frasier for
the couple extra minutes there.
>> No, no, no problem. Yeah, no, I
appreciate that things have have
remained very technical. Um I want to do
as much as I can to give some more
examples. In the meantime, uh I will be
answering questions um actually this
time. Um and and I think I'll create
some animations that I that I did last
time for this chapter as well because
this is quite a visual um idea that
we're talking about here. So, thank you
very much. Thank you for your patience
and we'll pick up next time with some
more practical stuff. Um, I look forward
to to what seeing what we can do. So,
stop the recording. We'll see you
YouTube people later. Bye-bye.